l'accès à une consultation médicale dans
une clinique sans rendez vous au québec
n'est pas facile pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas de médecin de famille il faut
souvent attendre tôt le matin pour
garder sa place encore se rabattre sur
l'urgence sur les services d'urgence des
hôpitaux ce qui augmente les délais pour
tout le monde
le système rendez vous santé québec sera
offert gratuitement des citoyens vont se
retrouver dans une situation similaire à
celle de réserver un billet d'avion ou
une ferme d'hôtel sur un fip
la médecin lui mais sa disponibilité et
le citoyen lui prend rendez vous soit
avec pas mille fins auxquelles la
personne est inscrite ou encore s'il n'a
pas de médecin
un médecin qui lui a des disponibilités
sur un rayon le ministre de la santé et
des services sociaux du québec gaétan
barrette
j'ai par exemple je voudrais avoir un
méfait rendez vous pendant deux
kilomètres de chez moi jusqu'à 2 kg et
là on y trouve par des suceurs quand
vous savez pas si vous savez pas laissée
sur ma port dans la loi 20 une provision
l effet que la loi s'applique
ils doivent participer à un système u
cinéma c'est sûr que c'est comme ça
qu'on voit des choses évident ici de
faire en sorte qu'on l'ait système qui
sont uniformes au québec en indiquant
ses coordonnées à l'intérieur de 20
kilomètres par exemple qui vient
possibilité d'avoir accès mais c'est
serré et c'est pas quelque chose dont on
n'invente rien on s'entend ici on fait
simplement rétracter ce qu'il fait
d'opposition dans d'autres avant elle
fait étape au canada ce dont on parle à
la presse affaires à la base le système
rendez vous santé québec les ventes
rien de nouveau et la grande inaction
d'un service privés payants disponibles
au québec depuis déjà maintenant cinq
ans je servais s'applique bonjour santé
permet aux personnes qui n'ont pas de
médecin de famille d'avoir une
consultation dans une tunique sans
rendez vous quarante cinq minutes avant
l'heure prévue de votre consultation on
va vous rappeler pour confirmer
vous diriez vous présentez là vous
diriger vers la clinique parce que votre
consultation va être effectivement
atteint 14
ce service a été mise en place en 2012
par son créateur
benoît brunel pour nous était impensable
qu'en 2012 il y avait encore des gens
sur le trottoir attend l'ouverture d'une
clinique saas a pas de bon sens qu'on
demande aux personnes âgées d'à les deux
ans sur le trottoir attendre technique
ruf pour l'instant pensa le service de
benoît brunel facture 15 $ du rendez
vous une initiative controversée dans un
système de santé qui se voudrait gratuit
sans frais accessoires et sans passe
droit
nous on pense que c'est une créativité
que le québec met à la disposition des
patients des usagers justement tu aimes
de rendez vous saint frai et surtout les
cribles comme on semble vouloir le faire
pire blanc et directeur général du
regroupement provincial des comités des
usagers au québec moins que j'espère que
ça va donner comme avantage c'est avoir
des rendez vous rapidement
donc si on peut se faire traiter dans
son groupe de médecine familiale à ce
moment là ça va être un avantage
toutefois je dois dire quelque chose
peut-être pour mettre un petit bémol est
ce que ça veut dire par là que le mix le
docteur barrette men croix pour ce que
tous les comics les usagers du réseau de
la santé
un médecin de famille en 2018 je crains
que peut-être que ça ça nous donne
peut-être un constat d'échec étant donné
qu'on nous dit qu'on va prendre avoir
accès à tous les médecins
le but premier était d'avoir accès à son
médecin de famille bien sûr vont venir
bien sûr on va pouvoir avoir accès à un
médecin mais je crois qu'il est toujours
important de garder en tête l'objectif
que 85 % des québécois et un médecin de
famille d'ici la fin de l'année
un reportage de radio canada
international